I noticed just a strange effect in my my
left hand I couldn't open it completely
without forcing it but I was so active I
just heard I had pinched a nerve in my
back I discovered that I was pregnant
and then soon forgot about what was
happening to my body until mid pregnancy
I couldn't ignore it any longer and then
I saw a neurologist they diagnosed me
with Parkinson's complete shock didn't
even know how to react
the medication allows you to move my
body so that I can work out and the work
out here actually allows me to take less
medication
I started Rocksteady boxing and it was
almost like fire I slept better at night
I had more strength during the day with
Parkinsons a lot of the symptoms
involved balance and gates and so boxing
naturally challenges that and so balance
really improves gait improves people
note that their tremor reduces our
fighters range in age from 39 years old
up to their mid 80s
forty's it's like the last thing you
expect to happen to yourself and then
when it does you either give up or you
keep fighting and coming to rock city
boxing helps us to keep fighting